un bâtiment quasi neufs et une surface
doublée par rapport à l'ancien il y a un
an
les ateliers panel ont quitté créancey
pour venir s'installer ici à longvic les
effectifs en personnel ont également
augmenté
aujourd'hui quarante sept équivalents
temps plein mais si le carnet de
commandes continue à progresser
pas sûr que l'entreprise passe
immédiatement le seuil des 50 salariés
il ya quand même la mise en place de
certaines normes au niveau légal et
sociales qui sont compliqués et qui
impose des coûts de mise en place d'une
part et des coûts de temps aux hommes
en règle générale pour faire court on
est obligé de mettre en place un rh dans
l'entreprise ce qui n'existe pas dans
notre organisation aujourd'hui et c'est
un coût de personnel
quoi qu'il arrive qui est en plus et qui
est productif autre frein les problèmes
de trésorerie acquérir de nouveaux
marchés c'est dépenser de l'argent en
matières premières et en personnel avant
d'être soi même payé par son client
et c'est parfois un casse tête pour les
entreprises aucun organisme très peu
d'organismes financiers
ce soit les banques les autres types de
partenaires permettent de faire des
prêts ou du financement de cette
trésorerie et là c'est un levier complet
sans cette trésorerie là l'entreprise
obligés de restreindre son développement
ce qui est quand même assez dingue
le medef travaille actuellement pour
fédérer les acteurs qui pourraient
permettre ce financement
une façon aussi de pallier une
spécificité française la réticence
fréquente des pme à ouvrir leur capital
à des investisseurs